we're told that david hosts a podcast
and he's curious how much his listeners
like his show he decides to start with
an online poll he asks his listeners to
visit his website and participate in the
poll the poll shows that 89 percent of
about 200 respondents love his show
what is the most concerning source of
bias in this scenario
and well like always pause this video
and see if you can figure it out on your
own and then we'll work through it
together
let's think about what's going on he has
this population of listeners right over
here i'll assume that the number of
listeners is more than 200 and he says
hey i want to i want to find a sample to
and i can't ask all of my listeners who
knows maybe he has 10 000 listeners they
don't tell us that but let's say there's
10 000 listeners here and he says well i
want to get an indication of what
percent like my show
so i need a sample but instead of taking
a truly random sample he asks them to
volunteer he asks his listeners to visit
his website so that's classic volunteer
response sampling this is non-random
because who decides to go to his website
and listen to what he just said and he
maybe even has access to a computer
that's not random in fact the people
more likely to do that so the people so
these are the people out of the 10 000
so these are the 200 responses here who
decide to do it
these are
more likely to be the people who already
like david or like to listen to what he
tells them to do the people the
listeners who aren't not into david or
you know or don't want to do
or don't want to do what he tells them
to do well they're unlikely to be and
say oh i'm not really into david and i
don't like him telling me what to do but
hey i'm going to go to his website
anyway i'm going to fill out that poll
that's that's less likely or you might
get extreme so people who really don't
like him might say i'm going to
definitely go there but in this case i
would say that it's more likely your
your fans are going to do what you ask
them to do and go to your website and
spend time on your website and because
of that that 89 is probably an
overestimate
89 percent is probably an overestimate
of the number of listeners who really
love his show because you're more likely
to get the ones who love them to show up
and fill out that actual survey
now these other forms of bias response
buys this is when you're asking
something that people don't necessarily
want to answer truthfully or the way
that it's phrased it might make someone
respond and you say in a biased way
classic examples of this are like you
know have you lied to your parents uh in
the past week or have you
ever
cheated on your spouse or something like
or have you do smoke any of these things
that people might not want to answer
completely truthfully or they might be
hiding from the world they might not
just want to answer that truthfully on a
survey and so you're going to have
response bias but that's not the case
right over here and under coverage is
when the the way that you're sampling
you're definitely missing out on an
important constituency you know
voluntary response we're likely missing
out on some important constituencies on
some people who might not be into going
to your website but under coverage is
where it's a little bit more clear that
that is happening now let's do another
case let's do another case maybe an
alternate reality where david's trying
to figure this out again he's still
hosting a podcast and he's still curious
how much his listeners like his show but
he tries to take a different sample he
decides in this case to pull the next
hundred listeners who send him fan
emails they don't all respond but 94 out
of the 97 listeners polled say they
loved his show what is the most
concerning source of bias in this
scenario
well this is a classic hey i have a
group i have a sample sitting in front
of me it's in my inbox on my email let
me just go to them isn't that convenient
so this is classic convenience sample
and this isn't just like hey you know
these are the first hundred people to
walk through the door and there's you
know a lot of times you could argue why
that might be not so random but the next
hundred listeners who sent him fan
emails so these these are this is a this
is convenient sampling and the the
sample that you happen to use out of
convenience is one that's going to be
very skewed to liking you so once again
this is overestimating
over estimating the percent
the percent that love his show
now non-response is when you ask a
certain number of people to fill out a
survey uh or to you know to answer a
questionnaire and for some reason some
percent do not fill it out and you're
like well who were those people maybe
they would have said something important
and maybe their viewpoint is not
properly represented in the overall
number that actually did fill it out and
there is some non-response going out
here he asks a hundred people
who sent fan emails to to fill out the
survey to say whether they love it or
not 97 fill it out so there were three
people who did not fill out the survey
so there is some non-response going on
that would be a source of bias but it's
not the most concerning you know right
over here they're asking us fill out the
most concerning source of bias and the
convenience sampling is definitely the
biggest deal here there were three
people who didn't respond but that's not
as big of a deal
voluntary response sampling well he
didn't ask people like in the last
example of like hey if you can go here
and
and and uh
fill it out i guess there is actually
actually no i'll take that back there is
a little bit of voluntary response here
where he goes to these hundred people
and he asks them to respond and so you
have the 97 people who choose to respond
but once again that could be a source of
advice
a bias but most of the 97 of the 100 are
responding and once again the most
concerning thing is the convenience
sampling which will once again based on
this this sample that he's happening to
use out of convenience is going to be a
very a significant overestimate in terms
of representing the entire population of
his listeners